before
you went to leo burnett we were creating
some sick [ __ ] advertising we were
so my question to you is what made you
want to go work
for an ad agency when we were basically
creating like sick ads on our own
we were basically like entrepreneurial
creating right we were on the phone
selling [ __ ] to hulk hogan
right but you still you wanted to go
work for an
agency like what i personally never
understood that so i'd be interested to
hear like your thoughts on
or what you were feeling what made you
want to do that honestly i felt like
what we were doing wasn't really mine
i felt like it was you concrete is you
and i was just there helping you realize
a vision
and what solidified that and what you
know made me ultimately leave was when
we were doing the hulk hogan video
and at the end said produced by danny
jones
well originally it said produced by
danny jones and luke james
yeah but in front of hulk hogan you said
take your name off
you got to put in your time right so
that didn't sit right with me so i was
like well
i see that he's in this for himself so
i'm gonna go out and see what else is up
and so then i went out saw what else was
up worked at a place in tampa
got to work on the florida lottery that
was cool it was
like a one-time reaction to that moment
no
that wasn't a reaction to that because i
didn't like leave until a couple months
after that
that was just something that never
really sat right with me oh so it was
like
so you're saying it was that one moment
that you kind of dwelled on and you
thought about and that moment was kind
of like a turning point for you that
really hurt my feelings
it really hurt your feeling yeah dude i
thought we were in it together
so that was you would say that that was
like
a legitimate turning point for you that
you like made a decision like you
dwelled on it for a while
obviously yeah and that was a reason you
made a decision to
go work for ad agencies for just because
was it because you wanted to like learn
more or was it because you just wanted
to get away from what i
from from me i felt like well obviously
yeah i wanted to learn more because like
yeah we were doing cool [ __ ] obviously i
can obviously
you were resentful about that moment i
could see that anyone would be resentful
yeah yeah and i also wanted to learn
from people that have
done it you know it's like yeah we could
like
crank out cool [ __ ] like all day up
there
but i feel like i wasn't really learning
anymore and i love learning big fan of
learning and like
trying new things seeing what else is
out there so i just wanted to go like
work for people that have like been in
advertising and done like
big campaigns and like i've studied
advertising writing and studied like
positioning and messaging and
everything that goes into making a
successful ad yeah see how i could do
that to make
myself a better creative i feel like i
did that
i feel like i came back a little bit
stronger and sharper than i did when i
left just kind of
like a really long journey coming back
to the same place but
i'm grateful for it yeah how did you
feel about it when i left
when you let oh dude i was [ __ ]
crushed
yeah i was [ __ ] crying sweet pea
[ __ ] it was like you came over early
yeah and she was still asleep
i don't public's bag full of hard drives
yeah
yeah she woke up to me literally on my
couch sobbing
like didn't know what the [ __ ] to do i
had like a johnson jewelers commercial
do the next [ __ ] day
yeah you just dumped all the [ __ ] in my
lap i was [ __ ] pissed off
i'm like what the [ __ ] how can this
[ __ ] [ __ ]
just drop all this [ __ ] when we know we
know we have [ __ ] dude
like how can he not give me a warning
like well the reaction was terrible
i mean the initial reaction was terrible
but um
but yeah i mean you know big picture
after like
thinking about you know talking to you
about it and learning from it i mean
obviously it's just
it's just a learning it's just growth
it's just like being young and stupid
making mistakes
yeah you know everyone everyone is
selfish sometimes everyone
everybody's selfish you know some people
more than others but
you gotta trip and fall in your face and
get up from it and learn from it
if you're gonna get better so
but yeah it was devastating it was
[ __ ] up we didn't talk me and you
didn't people
me and this guy didn't [ __ ] talk for
like five years that was a while
five years and me and shane would it was
like an ongoing joke with me and shane
for the whole five years
me and shane still talked every day and
we'd always make jokes about you i'm
like hey
you wonder if you think luke would want
to go with us here like
let's hit up luke we would still like
the way we and you talked me and you and
shane talk every day on the group chat
that was consistent through that whole
hiatus it was just like
you're just so funny making fun of you
without being there
except you know we weren't really making
fun of you we were kind of like
like full circle making fun of me right
because we know that i was the reason
that you weren't you didn't [ __ ] with
both of us yeah that's how you know it's
like some real hatred
like i don't [ __ ] with either of you
like you're not i ain't [ __ ] with you
either
yeah your proximity is on [ __ ] with a
ball
i can't go over there oh bro and shane
would call me every time he saw he was
like bro
is that the [ __ ] uh what's the bar
with the finger in front of it
downtown with the finger that points
down to the door no the bends the bed i
was at the beds i saw luke
luke's dirty moaning i made eye contact
with the lookster i said hi
oh man no yeah it was a it was a
hilarious daily ongoing inside joke with
me shane and sweetpea for five years
yeah
i'm glad we patched it over he knew knew
why more than anybody because she knows
me better than anybody
yeah she knows how difficult he can be
exactly how i am she knows exactly how
you know
selfish i was yeah you still am probably
but more so back then you're better
but um i noticed it i recognized it yeah
and uh
dude i mean that would give me some
credit that was a high pressure
situation
you handled it no no the hulk hogan
situation
when hulk hogan was standing over our
shoulders and
we were like who's andre put and i'm
like huh
they were both there they were there the
graphic was made
the reason the reason it only has one
name at the end of the video
called me beforehand and he was like bro
how can we have two [ __ ] names
directed by at the end don't put this on
[ __ ] hulk
we can only have two names put this on
hold on i don't buy that
goddamn side i had hulk with his [ __ ]
thumb on my head
and i had you with your [ __ ] i'm
about to leave again your boot on my
throat and i had to make a decision in
the moment
and i made the coward decision i'll
admit to it
i don't know if i believe that but it's
a good story true it is true the history
about
about hulk he made a comment about the
two names being on it
and you know when he questioned i mean
obviously if he did if the same thing
happened now and anybody questioned me
like that i would obviously take
your side over because because because i
realize now
i'm not anything nothing means anything
without the [ __ ] people that i'm
surrounded with because yeah what the
[ __ ] am i going to sit here and
talk like it's like a podcast like the
podcast 95
of the reason anybody watches any of
these videos is because of the people i
bring on
right not because of me they don't like
watching being this your turn to
your time to shine though yeah well
anyways i've realized that
the talent around me is the reason that
i'm able to do anything yeah
so it's good to realize that because you
know as you realize that like
you can stop using people to like
obtain things but you can start like
collaborating with people and bringing
people up with you and like really
connecting with people when you're not
you don't have some like outside
interest in like using their skills for
something like somebody sitting here
like you're
genuinely interested in the people
sitting here you're not just using them
for
what they may or may not do for you like
this is just what you do yeah like you
actually have like a
an interest in person i think the
podcast has helped you grow like you're
still a [ __ ] idiot
for sure 100 but you know i feel like
you've
gone more empathetic since you started
this and since like
we since i went from not talking to you
to talking to you
something happened in there where it was
just like oh maybe i should figure out
how to not be such an [ __ ] all the
time
what's up world you just watched a clip
from one of our exclusive
patreon episodes that's right you can
get weekly pure
uncut content straight from the jungles
of columbia if you want to watch the
full episode make sure you go to
patreon.comconcretevideos
peace
you